The Internet is an extraordinarily complex creature, using a
wide variety of hardware and communication protocols. To help
make sense of it all, most any discussion of
networking begins with the notion of interconnection layers, an idea
that captures the most important relationships among the Internet's
components. Several attempts have been made to formalize these, most
notably the seven-layer OSI model, and the four layer
Internet protocol suite. We use a hybrid model here and
try to keep the discussion intuitive. The physical layer
refers to hardware that actually creates and transmits the
electronic and optical signals, as well as the protocols
for interpreting these signals as bits. This would include
the network interface card inside your computer, the modem
that your Internet service provider gave you or recommended
that you buy. For ethernet cable connecting your modem
to your computer, and even submarine fiber optic cables that
stretch across the world's oceans. Protocols are interpreting the
signals sent across these media include physical ethernet and sonnet.
The link layer covers the communication between peers on a
local network. The most trivial topology for a local network
is just point to point, where there is a
permanent link between two end points. We can also have
more complex topologies, however, where multiple nodes are all connected
to the same medium, and feel all each other's signals.
The challenge here becomes making sure that they don't
all talk at the same time. The link layer also
encompasses switching, where connections between nodes are made on an
as-needed basis to reduce the potential for crosstalk. The network
layer is responsible for end-to-end communication on the internet. When
you request a page from the Udacity website, the data
doesn't come directly from our servers, but goes through several
intervening machines. This process of routing the data, or figuring
out what path the data should take, belongs to the
network layer. Unlike other layers, which have evolved to include many
different technologies, the network layer is governed almost exclusively by
the Internet protocol and the system of IP addresses. Now, once
data reaches your machine, there has to be some way
of knowing which application it is intended for. Also, communication isn't
perfect, so we need some mechanism for detecting when data goes
missing, arrives out of order, or when the connection is overloaded.
Coping with these situations is the job of the
transport layer. And lastly at the highest level, we
have the application layer, which includes application specific protocols,
such as HTTP for web, SMTP for mail, etc.
The relationship between these layers is mostly one of
using. The link layer uses the physical layer to
accomplish its goal of enabling point-to-point communication across a
shared medium. The network layer uses the link layer
to accomplish its goal of end-to-end communication between two
machines on the internet. The transport layer uses the network
layer to accomplish its goal of reliable end-to-end communication
between applications. And the application layer uses the transport layer
to accomplish its goal, whatever it may be, whether
it's fetching a website, sending an email, or streaming a
movie. The plan for this lesson will be to
start at the bottom layer and move our way up.